alright so how do you guys think we can
make the debates better because I've
watched both of them as i said i went to
the last one i tweeted on the first
debate that technically these things
have not even been debates a debate is
where they present an idea and then two
or more people go back and forth on
these same ideas but basically what
we've seen is moderators ask people
questions catered to them so that they
can talk about their things so for
example Jake Tapper would focus with
Lindsey Graham on foreign policy because
he's a foreign policy guy right that's
not a debate that's just sort of lobbing
up softball so what do you think we can
do to make these things better I'm back
to let's make it fun and entertaining
and do it like the voice it comes on
three minutes to talk everyone Wolf
Blitzer they all have their back to him
yeah and as soon as he says one thing
that they like they turn around and he's
in that's actually not so you mask the
voices right yeah cuz otherwise they'll
know oh that's true that that's that's
not the worst idea I've ever heard I'm
just saying uh the last debate which was
on CNN was fantastic because they
instead of getting a journalist to
moderate it they hired Eddie Haskell he
just kept trying to get everybody to
pick fights with each other yeah like
now Donald Trump said to that you were
ugly what do you want to say to him yeah
so you're not a Jake Tapper guys that
what you're telling me no that was the
that was probably the worst by the way
Jake Tapper he just announced that
they're gonna be start doing
fact-checking of politicians with with
factcheck.org because apparently at CNN
they don't know how to do that so they
had to hire outside organization to
teach them how to fact-check that's CNN
nobody on Jake Tapper's staff really
knows what they're doing right so what
that is and why there was no real
questions and why there was no follow-up
there was no candy crowley moment at
this debate where they corrected Carly
Fiorina for being a crazy person and
saying blatant lies about Planned
Parenthood what reason they don't do
that because they don't want to alienate
any of the viewers that like these
people so what they'll do if they say
hey Jeb Bush said this Donald Trump said
that what do you want to say to him
instead of saying hey the facts are this
you said this how do you they don't do
that so they're not doing journalism
they're doing Eddie
ilysm and they're trying to get people
to pick fights with each other yeah I do
agree with you but on the other hand
that question needed to be asked to
Carla fear good what's the face thing
that needed to be asked oh ok now about
Trump saying you know calling around on
what her looks or whatever I mean that
is right so arable that it needed to be
out right so I agree with you it had to
be addressed because it was just another
absurdly misogynistic thing that that
Trump did but interestingly doesn't that
then get more of the play the next day
than anything that might be more
important such as foreign policy or
immigration I mean really can you think
of any headline the next day that was
related to policy sorry I'm not are
important things but it's important how
a person who is running for president is
treating the women of this country yeah
I totally is important I totally and the
GOP did make it clear that they welcome
all women into the GOP even the ones who
make Donald Trump wins oh alright so we
haven't had a democratic debate yet we
have one in a couple weeks in vegas
right um as I said it about in our
Bernie segment you know the Democrats
are supposed to be the big party that's
what everyone says they're supposed to
be the big party but they've really only
got two people running for all intents
and purposes right Hillary and Bernie
then there's Jim Webb and an O'Malley
well but but it's really only two people
that anyone's talking about so should we
give the Republicans a little credit for
at least they have 20 clowns in their
clown car while in the Democratic clown
car there's really only two people well
Martin O'Malley did come out last week
with a bold proposal he said raise the
age of gun ownership to 21 years old and
everybody responded by saying who the
[ __ ] is Valley but that's my point you
know what I'm gonna cost call something
crazy here I think that that guy who's
polling at negative 60 that nobody knows
who he is I think he has a little bit of
a chance here because I think they're
all gonna get equal footing and people
are so sick and he'll I'm not on the
debate yeah and I think I think it will
bring him a good looking middle aged guy
and I think he's a pretty decent guy and
I think people are suddenly know who the
hell is this guy the irony is that it
was Howard Dean who whose idea was to
limit the number of Democratic debates
because he saw what happened with all
the Republican debates last time and how
they ate each other and how it was just
a clown show and so he didn't want that
to happen with
democrat so they made them limit them
but now we realize hey there's actually
going to be a real debate now so maybe
we should do more of these because this
is just free advertising for the
Republican Party yeah and we're not
getting any for the Democrats and people
still don't know where Bernie Sanders is
right so what can what can we do we got
look the election is over a year away
right what can we do to make these
debates better like it as the people
like we have to demand that they have to
be done on PBS I mean they were done I
don't know there's gonna be any of this
upcoming year but four years ago some of
them were done up here I mean something
how do we get it out of the gotcha thing
out of the does Carly have a wrinkle
right face oh no what the answer for
that is I mean it is gonna be
interesting to finally see Bernie and
Hillary go at it you know but how do you
make it more interesting and maybe they
you need to have someone like at the
Oscars who did the little clips always
beforehand you know what I mean to life
Billy Crystal come in and write I don't
know it or I mean what are you well it
won't be it used to be that the League
of Women Voters used to organize debates
and other people used to and then they
got smart and they were like hey we
can't let other people choose the people
are going to ask us questions we want to
control everything so they created this
presidential commission on debates and
now they're so now there isn't any more
wheat league of women so it's all them
controlling everything which is why they
suck right so somebody has to stand up
like maybe women or some other big
organizations say hey we want to have
our own debate like the n-double-a-cp
member saying we're gonna have our own
debate at our thing and we were inviting
people and then it'll be telling who
doesn't show up right so that's the way
they should do it unfortunately we know
the parties won't the parties won't back
that they won't because they have but
Bernice channel to show up Bernie will
show up and he'll do it alone but maybe
that would be good all right so let's
move on to what I think was the big
elephant in the room or unfortunately
not much Jimmy Dore a giant out of it
but the money in politics thing it is
seems pretty obvious to me that we have
a couple like real issues in America
right now the money in politics that's
ruin our political system we've got you
know political correctness run amok but
nobody talked about money in politics as
I said before I think I might've been
the only person that asked him a
question on this
why do we not talk we did talk about it
wasn't there a mccain-feingold thing
yeah teen years ago we used to sort of
talk about it every now and again nobody
talks about now right talk about it I
don't understand how we allow people to
run for president as a candidate when
they still owe money from the last they
try right literally I think Hillary
might be in debt still from the
previously if you owe money from the
last time you didn't get elected done
you can't run this time until you've
paid everybody off it is striking and
outrageous that people don't mention it
or talk about it I think it's terrible I
mean it's that's the only answer I mean
what how do you fix that though how do
you fix that well I did notice that when
I asked some of the campaign people this
and even when I asked Scott Walker they
just they just linked a couple words
together to put to make a sentence and
then you move on because they know
they're not going to be asked this and
they know no one cares that's what I
really realized that when I asked them
that there was a sense of that that
stupid question like nobody cares about
that asked me to ask me the got your
question you know so what do we do about
that you know we wolf dash pack.com Dave
that's how we need there's a bunch of
work that's the organization i'm a part
of that helps get money out of politics
and what you have to do is you have to
pass a constitutional amendment right to
get money out of politics hillary
clinton by the way said she's in favor
of it so we don't and we'll that'll be
that's good to hear also the Senate also
if the united states congress also
passed a resolution to open debate on
this well that's a good thing and three
states since we've been trying to push
this i've already passed the california
being one of them illinois and i think
we have new hampshire of vermont so
that's what you need to do you need to
get the state's you have to go to the
state level they have much less
controlled for whatever reason on the
state capital sure so we can make an so
that's my big solution we have to get
money and you can't fix anything why are
we still debating climate change because
big money right why are we still
debating wish we drill in the Arctic cuz
of big money I why are we still bombing
non-stop for 30 years in the middle
these big money so is that vessel that's
really the crux of it that the reason we
can't get the public to be jined up
enough to care is because they're
getting their information
from the very people who are paying the
operation to keep them dumb the
criminals bought the watchdog right the
watchdog used to be the Walter Cronkite
in 60 minutes and then they got smart
and said hey let's just buy them yeah
and they bought them and so now the guys
who are working for the people are
supposed to be exposing so that's why
they are literally working so that's how
you go well how do week so how do we get
it at a rack war that lasted that's how
you get it because the people are
working for defense contractors they're
supposed to be exposing defense count
directors and they're not that's what's
wrong I think there's a reality where
it'll ever turn around yes I think if we
get money out of politics and so so
Teddy happen before right so Teddy
Roosevelt came along and he did the
antitrust legislation right they used to
call him trust back then because they
would take anyway that was the so now
that's what we need we need him and then
we need FDR FDR stood up and said never
before in the history of America has the
money people been more organized in
their hatred for one candidate and I
welcome their hatred could you imagine
can you imagine anyone anyone saying
that today besides Bernie sander right
so you I had a little inspiration from
you first because it sounded like it
could happen but then I just thought
well if we get Hillary as president or
let's say we get Jeb Bush pretty sure
they're not making that speech I think
we're gonna have a revolution if that
happens we may well never it I'm gonna
buy a gun yeah all right so let's uh
let's talk about religion in politics
because that's the other big one and
look a guy Mike Huckabee's up there this
is a guy that the week before was
defending Kim Davis everyone knows about
Kim Davis and not giving the marriage
licenses to gay people and Mike Huckabee
actually defended her by saying you
shouldn't you shouldn't you know partake
in a law that you don't believe is moral
that is the most ridiculous
anti-american thing you could possibly
do it shows a profound lack of
understanding of how government works at
our Constitution and all that so but
there's there's him there's Cruz there's
Santorum and these gay and even now ben
Carson what do we do about this
conversation religion should have
nothing we have separation of church and
state I think what do we do about two
well I was googling this topic matter
earlier and I saw that the Boy Scouts
don't allow
in the Boy Scouts right and I was
thinking its people don't want to trust
other people who aren't religious or can
pretend to be religious you know with
decisions that are going to impact them
I kinda get it but on the other hand
have you ever been around I have ants
that are so religious they are evil you
know have you ever been around people
like that yeah you know I went to
Catholic school right right that's what
you mean and and when I look at the
Republican spectrum out there the
candidates I'm like oh my god these
people are equal yeah if you have
blinders like this about religious and
how everyone has to follow the same
religion or the same thing that you're
doing I mean that is just as bad as
someone who has a void of it and I know
that's just as bad as those horrible
agents we don't want to hurt anyone I
want people to live with secular values
I know it's just as equally horrible wow
what is this is this the irony of is
this the irony of Republicans that they
say they want small government right yes
they say they want small government and
then at the same time they keep jamming
do you read my no everyone I did note
because you said your question is how do
we get real engine out of government and
my whole thing is they should be made to
go to an religious people should have to
take an irony class yeah right right AB
Kim Davis who's thrice divorced making
us religious stand for the sanctity of
marriage yeah that's you know and now
the oath keepers have promised to defend
her in case they don't want to lock her
up again right she's so grateful she
promised to marry three or four of them
yeah so and then they played that song
right door with a dagger and so when she
came out and she and they that she got
in trouble for that because they don't
want her survivor doesn't wanna use that
song yeah she said she liked that song
so much she's gonna play it in her next
three weddings the point is Dave I have
a lot of these joke yes I got there and
she ruined rocky for me it's like yes so
but what about Huckabee so someone like
Huckabee who's suppose it like to me
this is this is proof that he's not
running for president and he's running
to run the Christian Right yes and I
wish people would just say that I wish
almost he could say that and he could
you know what I'm up on this stage
because I do control or at least want to
control a portion of this country and I
want to keep controlling it and then we
could be honest about it and then he
would disappear when he gets yeah when
the primaries go further but he's not
really running for president right isn't
he running to own that degree of power I
think you're a very perceptive day this
is I think why you have your own show
once in a while and yes that is exactly
what he's doing he's running to get
speaking fees he's running to be the
biggest Christian on stage sonam whoever
does become president he's like the
Billy Graham they have to come through
him to get to the religious right that
they're gonna need so it's all that he's
the biggest charlatan of all of them
yeah because at least Donald Trump who's
a big [ __ ] won't take that extra step
of putting the cross on his sleeve like
like Huckabee was and Huckabee's
complete phony right and then Trump not
that I ever wanted to fend Trump but you
know they asked Trump about the gay
marriage thing and he said look the
Supreme Court made a decision I i would
have to abide by the Supreme Court that
shows a better understanding of how
government works then Santorum or
Huckabee who want you to just pick which
laws can't imagine if we could all just
pick well i'm not gonna pay taxes
morally I don't think I should have to
yeah separate but equal so that means we
can just ignore it no that sounds like
huh right but i do like what you're
saying about he's running to get a
speaking engagement but then the reality
is how much money is he spending to try
to run for president versus how much he
would actually ever make as ass but he's
not spending his own money right so he's
not yeah right it's not it's not his and
ultimately it's not about the speaking
money per se as much as just the
influence that he will just one the
Christian Right like be the next Billy
grammar son but I want to back up to
saying that you said earlier about this
this atheist thing because the first two
episodes of the show we had sam Harris
who's probably the most outspoken
atheist one of my outfit is what if
Jimmy's favorite is I love and Cara
Santa Maria also an atheist and we
talked a little bit about atheists in
politics and every poll shows that
people would never vote for an atheist
people hate atheists why are we so
afraid of secularism I think this is
sort of what you were saying before but
why are we afraid of people that would
that would base their decisions on the
law of the land and not the imaginary I
think it's because everyone has this
like ultimate fantasy
you get to be President something
terrible goes down somewhere he has his
finger on the button right like what
what's going to happen you want to know
that your president is going to be in
that dark space in his room before you
has to make some terrible decision like
dear God you want the comfort of knowing
it's a whole facade it's a fake but you
want that you know anything you don't
want someone that's just like and this
is the line the column of good things
that'll happen this is the column of bad
things I think because people want to be
able to hang hope on a president and as
weird as it sounds I think what it is
you don't hang up on you know sorry I'm
sorry okay that's so I think it's the
same thing with gay people people were
against gay marriage until they knew a
gay person and I think people are afraid
of atheists until they know an atheist
yeah I was against gay marriage till I
got gay married eat them now I'm okay
with but I'm what do you think about I
that's what I really think it is yeah
people just don't know atheists and they
think well they're taking monday in fact
they kind of be quitting with devil
worshippers right you know it's like you
know there are no worshiping yeah
nothing which is exactly why I've been
saying on the show repeatedly yeah the
atheists have to come out i think the
Atheist movement should do that the most
important thing that gay people ever did
was come out and I think that that's
what's next for atheism maybe we should
start calling ourselves something else
like I like the term non-theist yeah I
like that it sounds better doesn't it's
like I'm not into the [ __ ] right but
don't you hate that you can have to
associate with the term doesn't that in
itself it's like then you're in the club
and yeah what club would want me kind of
thing yes and that yes and I don't agree
that there's such a thing as militant
atheism I don't I don't agree that's
like saying you're militant logical
person yes i will apply logic like box
every situation right you know all these
atheists that are getting rallies
together to hurt people it's just not
happening
you